came over to me earlier you said mark
I'm going to talk about the Knicks today
I think I said an expletive and then
said who's suffering well for Dolan if
investors are happy then he doesn't feel
the heat and he feels justified in
telling disgruntled fans to go ahead and
root for the Nets let's show you why
fans are so upset right now
the Knicks currently have a 192 winning
percentage the next Worst team is
Minnesota which has one more victory
than the Knicks the peak in this chart
was 2013 when the Knicks made it to the
second round of the playoffs
the average winning percentage during
this period this five-year stretch sub
500 were almost two-thirds of the way
through the current season which means
my producer superfan Jamie is almost
rooting for the Knicks to lose so they
have a better shot at getting the first
pick in the draft
now here's part two to this story msg
stock it yesterday closed at a record
high and today opened up before losing
ground and over the past five years it's
jumped about 300% what's driving this
out performance mark solid earnings and
Dolan's plan into perhaps splitting up
MSP his latest proposal is perhaps
spinning off the msg television network
which airs Knicks in New York Rangers
games and keeping the sports teams and
the entertainment business altogether
scarlet whatever path mr. Dolan chooses
MSG's fortunes are tied to the Knicks
fortunes so a bad season it can't be
good for the company well you would
think so but the numbers really indicate
that Dolan doesn't have a lot to worry
about at least for now because as you
said the Knicks have the worst record in
the NBA out of 30 teams but they lead
the way in average ticket prices they're
in first place and attendance is still
very respectable now according to
Jeffrey's analyst John Geneva's the
Knicks terrible play does create a drag
on advertising growth and concession
revenue but the impact is fairly modest
when it comes to ticket sales and the
team's economics are improving as well
because the luxury tax will likely get
lower even possibly eliminated in coming
seasons and their new national TV deal
is more than double the existing deal
and yield about a 50% margin on top of
that if Dylan were to ever sell the
Knicks unlikely but if you were he'd
probably fetch at least a two billion
dollar price tag Wow and Scarlett
there's the other pros
Forte's team that msg owns the new york
rangers your new york rangers there at
least playing better than the next they
are at least playing better than the
knicks and if the season were to end
right now they would make the playoffs
but the star goalie Henrik Lundqvist
also their most expensive player is out
with a neck injury he took a puck to the
neck and his replacement has been a
little bit shaky in the net so that is
one concern but even more so the Nick
the Knicks aren't doing well the Rangers
are doing well so yes MSU was able to
raise ticket prices on the Rangers by 3%
for this season while they didn't change
the Knicks prices for this season but it
doesn't matter as much to the bottom
line the Rangers are worth a lot less
than the next I mentioned two billion
dollars for the Knicks
the Rangers would fetch about 700
million dollars and Scarlets just
quickly what are analysts saying about
the stock analysts are excited about the
possible split of the company the real
moneymaker is of course in the regional
sports networks MSG and msg Plus and of
course this was all based on the
scarcity of live television and live
sports and that's where they're getting
excited